[Music]
so check out this amazing video of a
horse in australia who's got impressive
skills
on the keys
[Music]
[Laughter]
love it let's talk to this budding
musician along with his owner sophie
hi sophie
[Applause]
oh my gosh first of all holy
holy i was like she looks exactly like
patty griffin
did you see my face i was so confused i
was like
looks like patty griffin sophie has a
doppelganger
oh my god i love you so much hi
kelly congratulations on your second
season every really cool show i've been
watching
the game saying i'm gonna cry right now
you're the nicest human
ever like i named one of my dressing
rooms after you
right on like patty i'm crazy i know
every inflection
like every like i'm just singing
burgundy shoes right now
i love you so much i think that you are
so i even have a
i have a tattoo i'm like that i like
that fan that comes to see me at shows
i'm a tattoo of a kite
i love the kite i sing it to my children
ro every night like since they were
babies
i and it's the saddest song in the world
you probably shouldn't sing that to
children
but i do anyway and i think it's because
it sounds like a lullaby and you have
the most perfect voice and you were
like the my goal in life is to write one
song that is half as good as what you
write
and you're so great and anyway we've
we've been talking about the how music
heals have you been working on anything
new
asking for a friend um i'm plugging away
yeah it's it's been tricky times you
know i think
for some people it's super productive
and other people
i'm in the group of kind of confused
right now but
um yeah i'm plugging away plugging away
you've got to show up
do the work and something will something
will turn up eventually
right well i mean a lot of people plug
away patty and they show up and they
don't and it doesn't end up sounding
like what you do
so thank you so much this just made my
day
i had a really crappy morning for real
and this just made my day so thank you
so
much and you're wearing my favorite
color green
i love everything about you anyway i
can't wait for new music
let's hang out let's hang out let's hang
out sometime
don't you threaten me with a good time
[Music]